en fait si vous voulez pour contrer les
blocages qu'ils ont eu d'un point de vue
de ses de ces sites là en question
justement les sanctions qu'ils ont lu la
russie a subi par rapport à ces sites là
donc la russie a répliqué avec les armes
qu'elle avait à savoir les armes
numériques qu'elles ont c'est quoi
exactement donc là on est sûr que tu
étais pour ces autres sociétés wikipedia
youtube aussi car on à spotify discorde
wikipedia twitter facebook et twitter
c'est un petit peu foiré mon à facebook
youtube et se marrent cité qui ont été
évacuées effectivement cyberattaques et
et ça risque de se poursuivre encore sur
le long terme c'est que le début d'une
cyberattaque qui ne fait que commencer
en fait d'accord donc là vous allez nous
dire ce qui peut se passer dans un
instant vous allez voir c'est incroyable
vous allez voir que nous notre cyber
attaque il y en a parlé de cyberattaques
les hees a alerté tout le monde parce
que tout monde
actuellement et en alerte maximale pour
les aider on a été contacté vous allez
voir je vous expliquerai tout ça dans un
instant et idriss va nous parler de ce
qui peut se passer et c'est pas c'est
pas ou feint moi même je sens que vous
avez été cyberattaque est envoyé par eux
mêmes alors j'ai vu en fait ce qui s'est
passé sur la chaîne je me suis dit que
c'est également c'est un symptôme en
fait comme un docteur jack c'est un
saint comme d'une cyberattaque
effectivement j'avais proposé à votre
équipe une démo sur ce genre de
cyberattaques si moi j'avais fait une
démo ça aurait fait exactement la même
chose en soie dorée d'accord d'accord
moi je me suis tout de suite imaginé
d'une cyberattaque saluera taxes je sais
que vous avez ça c'est bizarre
on a eu donc nos deux cartes mais voilà
qu'une autre de 2 80 ans qui ont tué
hier encore ils ont dysfonctionné est ce
qu'il est possible de les voilà les
brûler ou les faire cramer à à distance
alors justement même titre qu'on peu
débridé une voiture où ma carte
graphique ou tout autre élément
informatique c'est probable que ce soit
quand même une cyber attaque même si
c'est que la carte sont la carte réseau
qui a été impactée on a très bien pu les
faire surchauffer à distance en vue en
fait s'il voulait augmenter la puissance
de ses cartes en question a atteint
jusqu'à atteindre des limites qui font
quelques rames est en fait que ça
donne et c'est vraiment c'est possible
de laisser totalement possible donc au
jour d'aujourd'hui c'est vos cartes son
avocate raison qu'on cramé mais ça peut
provenir d'une cyberattaque
effectivement c'est incroyable et puis
moi je crois pas aux coïncidences
coopération qui va on a eu trois ou
quatre à divers thermale donc je pense
quand même que font ces caisses qui
s'est passé quoi vous pensez y réussir
ben écoutez vous est calme et des
invités sur votre plateau qui était
quand même assez en lien avec la russie
je pense à riedisheim et trompe pas
effectivement ça peut déranger les
services russes qui ont des agents un
peu partout dans le monde qui peuvent
intervenir à ce niveau là c'est
incroyable même le ou même les propos
que les chroniqueurs nous on a eu aussi
les plateaux
est ce que par exemple il pourrait se
mettre en position de couper le faisceau
a abandonné précis imaginerait bien son
nom faire revenir sa gay il faut rien
pendant je pars une semaine et comme ça
qu'ils allaient qu'il parle up il coupe
tout cas moi je vous me faites venir
avec un simple pc une machine reste en
dehors du bâtiment et je bloque tout le
réseau n'avait pas fonctionné une
décharge et vous me payez le cabinet de
monsieur dupont moretti pour la lorraine
nancéen en mission sur la station
organise pour nous voilà parce qu'il
avait proposé de faire un destin
hybrides vont venir il se serait passé
exactement ce qui s'est passé hier alors
il serait passé ce qui s'est passé hier
et en plus de ça il aurait put sont dans
les micros tout ce qui touche aux ondes
en fête aurait été totalement impacté
est coupée donc tout ce qui est micro
pour vous pour vous pour vous décrire
c'est ça arrive tu vois que les deux
cartes voient la cram en même temps
choisissez c'est arrivé quand même à un
moment qui est un peu particulier donc
je me dis quand même y'a pas de ya pas
de hasard par rapport à ça pour moi
c'est une cyber attaque maintenant je
peux pas le prouver pour le moment je
crois que ça vaut machine ya vos
serveurs bien sûr mais pour moi c'est
une si ça vous avez accès à nos machines
à nos cerveaux pour il le dire bien sûr
mais maintenant bien sûr on pourrait
regarder même pendant l'émission nous
voir à la fin vous dire je voulais pas
mener le code wifi de l'émission vous
avez peur de moi
mais moi je connais pas ma pas le bon
rythme c'est qu'ils aient pas mourir
c'est pas moi je comprends
idriss c'est juste le fait possible il
faut il faut on va le faire le contraire
serait quand même assez particulier
entre la russie et l'ukraine et entre le
reste du monde si je peux me permettre
quand même on à la russie d'un côté qui
a une armée d'acker ils ont aussi à côté
le renseignement en l'occurrence le
gérer ils sont très puissants et sont
calmes dans le top 3 des pays qui sont
les plus puissants pour effectuer des
cyber attaques à travers le monde ils
l'ont prouvé d'après leur historique
donc pour moi ya pas de hasard il faut
savoir aussi qu'ils sont soutenus par
pas mal de groupes de hackers notamment
un groupe conti qui sont spécialisés
dans les rangs de somewhere d'accord le
plus finalement doit savoir ce que c'est
qu'un jeune chômeur je le détail est un
petit peu après et c'est pas mal de
groupes de hackers qui sont affiliés à
la russie et qui est de la russie
justement pour effectuer des attaques à
travers le monde pour tous ceux qui sont
qui sont contre poutine et kim d'accord
mais qui dévoile des choses qui sont pas
forcément apprécié par la russie oui j'y
vais vous parler éventuellement d'une
cyber attaque venant de russie qui
aurait touché aussi ses huit ça veut
dire que les services secrets russes
écoute l'émission et à un moment il ya
une réunion qui se passe au alors qu'à
moscou il décide de lancer une
cyberattaque contre plein de médias
différents frais survolé les services de
renseignement du monde entier ont des
gens dans le monde entier renseignements
france emond des gens au maroc que
soient partout en afrique en amérique
c'est pareil pour la russie et en voir
plus pour la russie donc c'est
totalement pris mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que nous on parle moins de la
russie oui mais voilà que d'autres
chaînes d'info mais vous avez hérité
seriez
mais notamment sur ses huit passes et
surtout sur ses huit fois sur internet
et beaucoup sur bfm beaucoup sur rfi
those who else et il était parmi n'est
pas bousculé peut-être que il dit pas la
même chose
ça va dit la même chose chez d'alléger
j'adore continu avec du parcours le
bouchon du
bruit si ça reste comme un pays très
puissant pour effectuer des cyber
attaques de l'autre côté la l'ukraine
qui n'ont absolument aucun acteur qui
n'en est rien la seule chose qu'ils ont
c'est qu'ils ont le vice premier
ministre monsieur fedorov qui a fait un
appel au monde entier en fait pour
demander à des hackers du monde entier
de les soutenir et par ce biais ils ont
quand même réussi à rééquilibrer la
balance on estime aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
récupéré entre 250000 et 300000 à coeur
à travers le monde pour pouvoir aider
l'ukraine à cyber attaques et en
conséquence alors à ce que les sur une
cyberattaque hydrique on peut se
défendre ou peu que attaqué anges en
fait il voulait on peut pas se défendre
et à certaines attaques on sait
simplement pas se défendre on s'attaque
soit la faiblesse des gens soit on
effectue des opérations qui font qu'il
n'ya pas de sécurité aujourd'hui qui
permettent de contrer ces attaques
maintenant la meilleure manière la
meilleure solution pour se protéger
d'une cyberattaque qui émane d'un pays
quand même c'est de cyber attaques et en
retour et de faire peur aux pays on
retournera à dire ça aux côtés je veux
pas le toucher parce que ils peuvent
passer seul truc en fait effectivement